a local family searching for a missing
woman this morning amanda elias in may
was last seen about a month ago metro
says the case is closed amanda's family
says it's anything but sasha loftus has
the story
crazy at times
but she's loving joanna kelly shares
what she loves most about her sister we
love her and we want to make sure that
you know she's okay she hasn't heard
from 40 year amanda elias in may since
november 9th and says the silence
between them is anything but normal the
fact that she hasn't talked to me
and i have her kids
is really concerning kelly tells us
amanda first came to las vegas from
pennsylvania with her boyfriend darion
bibbs clark county records show he was
arrested on november 19th metro police
tell us amanda was seen on video at a
local pawn shop a few days later on
november 24th so her missing person case
with the department was closed it's not
ok you know we're not getting any
answers but her family says no one she
knows has heard a word from her so as
far as they're concerned amanda still
needs to be found she just needs to let
us know that she's okay so they hope
this call for help will encourage others
to keep an eye out
and bring the person they love back we
just need to find her like so that we
can bring her home and give her kids
closure sasha loftis live local now
if you've seen amanda and you believe
she could be in danger please call metro
police we do have other resources
related to missing persons cases here in
the valley on 8newsnow.com